well I'm joined Now by Holocaust
Survivor Manfred Goldberg and Karen
Pollock who is chief executive of the
Holocaust educational trust are really
good to see both of you this morning
um Manfred how are you going to Mark
today
well I am
straight from here
being taken to 10 Downing Street for an
event which will be circulated I believe
among thousands of civil servants
I'm I've been asked to give a version of
My Testimony to which all these
uh civil servants we listened to
some of them I expect for the first time
I spoke to your receptionist while I
waited here and to my amazement he had
never heard the word holocaust
that's it's stunning isn't it when you
say that
um you were a little boy Manfred I was
11 years old when I was taken into the
camps and days after my 15th birthday
when I was liberated by a British tank
column
and Karen this is being marked all over
the world isn't it just tell us about
the importance of having a day
it is being marked across the world and
thank you for having us here today
um it's difficult for Manfred to share
his story in a few minutes but it's a
very harrowing testimony and one that
can take hours to listen to and even
when you've heard it it's so difficult
to comprehend and you know the
unthinkable Horrors that he experienced
and the loss that he went through is is
enormous and so people like Manfred the
survivors they are the brave people
reliving their story their testimony so
that people like me and you and your
viewers
um will know what happened during the
Holocaust and that the next generation
will continue to learn and carry the
legacy of Holocaust Survivors people
like Manfred and those people six
million Jewish men women and children
who were murdered so today
is a day for all of us as a nation and
across the world to come together and
remember but for people like Manfred he
remembers this every day this is part of
his life and we at the Holocaust
educational trust our job is of course
to highlight and amplify this
commemoration today but to work all year
round so that people never forget
and Manfred is the number of people who
survived uh dwindles it gets smaller and
smaller doesn't it
um how do you think is the most
effective way to keep the memory of
those atrocities uh in in people's minds
so that it can't happen again
there are quite a number of
organizations who are innovating highly
ingenious new methods of preserving
um testimony
given by survivors
I'm amazed that
hundreds of thousands of people
are denying that the Holocaust ever
happened while survivors like me who can
speak in the first person are still
alive
but that is a fact today
I
feel that it would be extremely
dangerous
and have consequences if the Holocaust
was relegated to just a footnote in
history it is absolutely vital to keep
that
horrific experience
which I believe was unprecedented in the
history of humanity alive in order to
make people aware
of what hate can lead to
I
think
that
in one way or another people will
achieve what we are saying that the
memory must be kept in front of people
also to to manfred's words and I hope I
think he won't mind me saying this but
you asked about the dwindling number of
survivors these are a small number now
precious people with important history
and experience to share and Manfred and
I both lost a very dear friend Ziggy
shipper who passed away last week on his
93rd birthday but Ziggy in fact is
somebody that Manfred met in the camps
during the Holocaust and they've been
friends ever since so you know Manfred
has lost somebody that he's known and
been friends with wealth for over seven
decades but this manifests this is the
example of the challenge we have and so
as Manfred says the Innovation that we
at the Holocaust educational trust and
others are involved in is to ensure that
these testimonies are preserved and
shared
yeah it's so important that we have not
just a day like today but that Manfred
that you do share your memories which
can't be easy uh for you at all but we
very much appreciate you coming on uh to
share them with us here on Sky News
today and we wish you all the very best
for your event at number 10 uh shortly
after speaking to us thank you very much
indeed